tag 3 der ukrainischen großoffensive in
der region raki vom osten des landes
umgehend anfangen mit ganz aktuellen
bildern aus dem ort jakowenko bei jako
vancouver einer von acht orten die seit
vorgestern abend von der ukrainischen
armee befreit worden die feier sechs
monate unter russischer kontrolle
standen und wie sehen es mittlerweile
vielleicht hier der panzer rollt also
durch dieses dorf und wir sehen die
menschen die rauskommen die die soldaten
begrüßen die also ja sich freuen denkt
man zumindest wenn man die bilder sieht
dass sie eben nach fünf bis sechs
monaten wieder nach russischer
herrschaft unter ukrainischer kontrolle
stehen wie geworden ist das ganze mal
auf der karte ansehen um auch vielleicht
die taktische situation dort mehr zu
verstehen ballack war ja ist die stadt
die hier etwa sich befindet und dort ist
die ukrainische gegenoffensive gestartet
sie hat ein gebiet schon von 200
quadratkilometern seit vorgestern
befreit und das glauben zumindest die
russen und das macht auch ein bisschen
sinn wenn man wenn man sich diese
strategische situation an sieht die
ziele der ukrainische offensive sind in
der tat easy um einmal hier im süden und
koblenz keiner hier im norden
schottlands die wichtigste großstadt in
der region aktiv die von russischen
autoren gehalten wird und easy um hier
unten ganz wichtig um auch die attacken
der russen richtung slogans und
grammatik also in die region donetsk
leben aufrechtzuerhalten insofern ist es
recht wahrscheinlich dass die ukraine
versuchen werden von ihrem brückenkopf
diese hier geschlagen haben richtung
koblenz und easy um vorzudringen und wir
wollen uns mal ansehen
welche merkwürdigen 10 sich dort
abspielen hier sind ukrainische soldaten
die in die nordbank gekommen sind wir
gucken mal was da oben wird das ist eine
flagge dieser monat lang gewählt hat vor
dem rathaus der stadt nicht etwa die
russische flagge sondern wir sehen
hammer und sichel das ist die
sowjetische flagge die russischen
okkupation scheinen zu glauben dass sie
die sowjetunion hier wieder errichten
dass sie die ukraine zum teil der
sowjetunion machen oder irgendeines ades
von gross russischen reich und insofern
hier auch die sowjetische flagge über
dem rathaus der stadt bayrak angebracht
haben die jetzt gestern wieder von
ukrainischen soldaten hier entfernt
wurde als die eben diesen ort zurück
erobert haben und wir sehen jetzt hier
noch mal die kamera mit relativen daran
um dann auch zu zeigen das ist
tatsächlich das rathaus von beirat die
ukraine machen das ganze natürlich zum
großen teil mit eigenen waffen aber auch
mit waffen die ihnen geliefert wurde
hier sehen wir was ihnen entgegenkommt
und wir haben es gerade ganz kurz
verpasst wirkung ist noch mal an was wir
hier sehen ist eine von zwei deutschen
panzerhaubitzen 2000 die hier also bei
der schlacht um kreativ gerade
eingesetzt werden wir sehen dazwischen
auch immer wieder kleine autos die
ukrainer das wissen wir haben viel zu
wenige gepanzerte fahrzeuge aber hier
ein zweites noch mal eine deutsche
panzerhaubitze 2000 die hier begrüßt
wird von dem anderen fahrzeug dahinter
ein haben wie aus den usa der das ganze
absichert insofern ist das ganze erneut
ein ein gemeinsamer ansatz wenn man so
möchte ein gemeinsamer kampf von
ukrainischen soldaten auf der einen
seite und ausländischen waffen aus den
usa aus deutschland aus großbritannien
auf der anderen seite um eben den
nordosten des landes die region
attraktiv zumindest mittelfristig von
russischen truppen zu befreien
[Musik]